e você mora logo vou cadê o cabo é 60 watts quando tem mais é
O que é isso? Sal com leite?
Sal com leite.
Obrigado.
Feito a água, foi?
Feito a água.
É, é, é.
E?
Pra, enfim, se não tiver o limite,
vou colocar a cheia na frente,
mas ele já foi pra ver a educação,
só que pra tirar as fotos da lenda,
pra tirar as fotos que tinha aqui,
tá, não sei, não sei,
enfim, não,
tipo assim, não tem hoje,
acho que tá chegando pra essa,
mas aí foi ele também,
é só assim,
não foi bem,
Esquecer, né?
Esquecer agora.
Desperta e deixa ligar, né?
Sim, é a informação que tu manda, né?
Ah, deve ter aproxado o negócio.
Tá tudo isso.
É só arroxar.
É?
Você não acha que tem que colocar...
Pega a música.
Legal.
Fone de atendimento?
O Grinder
Você está bem?
Está triste
Vai se molhar, não?